You know, we live in this really bizarre technological moment right now. I mean, if you sit down at your laptop today, you can ask an AI to write a completely original symphony, right?
Right. Or like generate a thousand lines of flawless Python code.
Exactly. And it does it in, what, three seconds? But then if you take this multimillion dollar state of the art robot and ask it to fold a pile of laundry.
Oh, it fails. Yeah. Just completely fails.
Yeah. It gets totally confused by like a wrinkled sleeve.
It's a really jarring contrast. We're seeing artificial intelligence conquer some of the most complex cognitive casks we can even dream up. But the physical world, it just remains incredibly stubborn. Yeah. Getting a machine to move through a messy physical
environment is, well, it's exponentially harder than getting software to navigate a database.
And that paradox, you know, why AI can think like a genius, but physical robots still stumble around like toddlers. That is the core of what we are unpacking in today's deep dive.
Yeah, it's a huge topic.
So our mission today for you listening is to take apart this brand new paper. It literally just published today, September 30th, 2026.
Rush off the presses.
Right. It's by Russell Legate Yang and Maxim Masenkov, and they're from Anthropics Economics team. And the title just asks this wonderfully straightforward question, which is what work can robots do?
Which is the question on everyone's mind. But to really answer that, we also brought in a stack of five older foundational economics papers from the last decade.
Right, because we need that context.
Exactly. We want to see if this new anthropic research actually confirms all those old theories about automation or if, you know, the recent explosion in AI has just totally shattered our previous assumptions.
So let's jump right in. Let's start with that physical bottleneck. To figure out what a robot can actually do, the anthropic authors realized they first had to define where the robot is trying to do it, right?
Yeah, because the environment is everything. And this traces directly back to one of our background sources, which is David Autor's 2015 paper.
Oh, the Why Are There Still So Many Jobs paper?
That's the one. Autor popularized this concept of environmental control, and he heavily relied on something called Polanyi's paradox.
I love Polanyi's paradox. It's
fascinating.
It's basically this observation that human beings know far more than we can actually tell. Right. If you think about riding a bicycle, you just do it. You feel the balance. But if you try to sit down and write out the exact mathematical physics equations required to maintain that
equilibrium, you'd go crazy. And most human physical labor operates on that exact same intuition. We adapt to chaos naturally. But to automate a task, you have to map all that chaos into rigid rules.
Which is why, historically, industrial automation has just been incredibly brittle. I mean, you can't just drop a robot into a messy room and tell it to figure things out. You have to meticulously engineer the entire environment around the machine. You remove
every single unpredictable variable just so the robot can perform one repetitive motion.
It's like the consumer robot vacuum effect.
Oh, perfect example.
Yeah. If you clear the floor, pick up your shoes, tuck away those rug fringes, your vacuum looks like an absolute genius.
But if you let it loose in a cluttered garage?
It gets hopelessly stranded on a single stray extension cord.
Exactly. So the anthropic researchers, they took that exact limitation and they operationalized it into a really strict rubric. They wanted real data, not just theories.
So how did they do that?
Well, they started with O-Net, which is the standard US database of occupations. They filtered through about 900 jobs, which encompasses roughly 19,000 specific tasks.
Wow. OK.
And from that, they isolated 7,594 tasks that are purely physical. OK.
So they have this massive list of physical tasks. But instead of just, you know, guessing if a machine could do them, they set the AI model Claude loose on the Internet. Right. They had Claude search for actual evidence of real deployed or demonstrated robots performing these actions.
And then they graded them on the scale from E0 to E3. Right. Based entirely on environmental control.
Yeah, the scale is brilliant in its simplicity. So E0 just means the robot simply cannot do it, no matter the environment. Okay. Then E1 represents a purpose-built robotic environment. So imagine like an automotive assembly line.
Where the factory is basically a giant steel cage built around the machine.
Exactly. Then E2 is a structured human workplace, like an Amazon logistics center.
Oh, right. So humans still work there, but it's highly standardized for machines. Flat floors, barcodes everywhere, super clear aisles.
Spot on. And then finally, there is E3, the unstructured environment.
Like a busy city intersection.
Or a messy construction site. Or a chaotic hospital emergency room.
Right. So walk us through a concrete example. Like, how strict is this rubric when you apply it to a real job?
Okay, the paper uses a great example, digging trenches. So if you run digging trenches through the model, Claude splits the job up by the amount of time each subtask takes.
Okay, makes sense.
And Claude finds that cutting a simple linear trench in open ground takes about 25% of a worker's time. And because there are autonomous excavators doing that exact thing outdoors today, that specific action gets an E3 rating.
Because the hardware can actually handle the unstructured dirt.
Right. But digging trenches isn't just mindlessly tearing up dirt. Another 20% of that exact same job involves careful, manual digging around buried pipes or, you know, delicate electrical conduit.
Oh, yeah. That requires tactile feedback.
Exactly. A human worker feels the resistance of a PVC pipe through the handle of their shovel, and they instantly stop pushing.
But a multi-ton excavator doesn't feel that. It just rips the pipe right in half.
Yeah, it destroys it. So when Claude searches for a robot with the fine motor skills to gently navigate unknown buried utilities, it finds zero evidence. That subtask gets slapped with an E0.
Wow. So the lack of tactile feedback completely breaks the capability.
It really does. And because the paper uses a majority rule methodology based on time, the delicate, impossible work outweighs the easy linear digging.
Ah, I see.
So therefore, the overall job of trench digging is ultimately classified by Anthropic as unexposed to robotics.
That is a brutal filter. But when they ran all 7,594 physical tasks through it, the numbers they came out with were still massive.
They really were.
I mean, technically speaking, robots currently have the capability to perform 74% of physical tasks. That maps out to 34% of all U.S. working time.
But, and this is a huge but, the devil is in the distribution. You have to ask where that 74% capability actually lives on the rubric. Right. The vast majority of it is locked in E1 and E2, those highly controlled settings. When you look at
tasks that require E3 capability operating in the messy real world, robots can only handle 1% of all physical tasks.
Wait, 1%? Just 1%. So we have this massive technical capability, but its actual footprint in the unstructured real world is just a sliver. Still, though, 74 percent in controlled environments is huge. It really begs the question,
who is standing in the crosshairs here?
Well, if you sort their index by the most exposed occupations, nine of the top 10 are vehicle operators.
Really?
Yeah. Taxi drivers actually take the number one spot across the entire U.S. economy with a score of 2.2 out of three.
You know, that actually makes perfect logical sense. A road is technically an unstructured E3 environment because of weather and pedestrians, but driving itself is a strictly rules-based system.
Exactly.
You stay between the painted lines, you stop at the red octagon, yield to the crosswalk. It's chaos, but it's highly regulated chaos. Plus, I mean, we've poured hundreds of billions of dollars into autonomous vehicle research to solve that exact problem.
We have. But we can't just look at physical robots in a vacuum. To get the full picture of the workforce, we have to layer this new physical data on top of the cognitive automation we mentioned at the start.
Oh, right.
And this is where two more of our background sources come in. There's a 2024 paper by Alundu and colleagues and an early 2026 paper by Massinkoff and McCrory.
And both of those studies looked at large language models, right?
Right. They measured how exposed jobs are to LLMs. And they found that LLMs alone expose about half of all work in the economy.
Which is already a huge number.
But when you stack Anthropic's new physical robot data on top of that LLM data, the combined number is just staggering.
It jumps to
81%. 81%. So between software that processes information and hardware that manipulates objects, four-fifths of all human work tasks have some vulnerability right now.
It's massive, but the demographics of who is exposed reveal a really profound split. The worker whose job is threatened by a robot is the statistical mirror opposite of the worker whose job is threatened by an LLM.
Yes.
This demographic flip is arguably the most fascinating part of the data for me. Because if you are in a job highly exposed to LLMs, you likely hold a bachelor's degree, you work in an office, and you have a relatively high income. Right. But if you look at the jobs exposed to
physical robots, those workers are a massive 55 points less likely to hold a bachelor's degree. 55 points. And they are less likely to be female. They earn on average $30 an hour less than the LLM-exposed worker. And they
already face more than twice the baseline unemployment rate.
It creates this distinct bifurcation. The cognitive wave is just washing over the white-collar, highly educated office worker, while the physical wave is grinding toward the blue-collar manual laborer.
OK, so we have this 81 percent exposure footprint. But, you know, exposure is just a theoretical vulnerability. It doesn't mean your boss is firing you tomorrow. Exactly. To understand if that exposure turns into actual job loss, we have to talk about money. We have to pivot from
what a robot can do to what a business will actually pay a robot to do.
Which brings us to a critical tension in labor economics. And this is perfectly illustrated by another one of our background sources, Frey and Osborne's infamous 2017 paper.
Oh, that paper caused absolute panic.
It really did. They predicted that 47 percent of U.S. jobs were at high risk of computerization. But their entire model was built on capability alone.
Right. They essentially argued the technology exists to do this task. Therefore, this job will disappear.
Yes. And the new anthropic paper pushes back on that violently. They insist that capability is an illusion if the economics don't make sense.
It's like commuting to work in a private helicopter.
Right. Exactly.
Like, is the helicopter technically capable of moving you three miles to the office and avoiding traffic? Sure. But the fuel, the pilot, the maintenance, it's economically absurd. You're just going to drive your car because the car is cheaper.
That is the perfect analogy. Because when the anthropic researchers actually ran the cost analysis on deploying robots, the results completely deflated that Frey and Osborne panic.
So what were the numbers?
Well, remember that 74% capability number? When you factor in the cost of buying, programming, and maintaining the hardware, robots are only cost competitive for 0.3% of job tasks today. Wait, 0.3%? 0.3%. That isn't a robotic
takeover. That is a rounding error. It really is. So let's break down the mechanics of this. Where does the math actually work and where does it fall apart? Where is
that 0.3% happening?
The clearest economic win right now is in packing and packaging. If you are putting standardized items into cardboard boxes, the robots are winning. A logistics company can buy a $2 million automated packaging installation that replaces roughly 14
human workers.
Okay, but $2 million is a massive upfront capital expenditure.
It is, but the mechanism of the savings justifies it. Because boxes are standardized. The machine doesn't have to think very hard. It just repeats a geometry problem over and over. Right. So when you amortize the cost of that $2 million machine
over its lifespan, the company ends up saving about $2,500 a year for every human worker it replaced. It's a slim margin, but at scale, it's highly profitable.
Okay, so standardization is the key there. What about a job where the robot fails the cost test miserably?
Welding is the perfect counterexample.
Oh, interesting.
We absolutely have AI-powered robotic welders. Right. They are highly capable. But a human welder just needs a protective mask, a welding torch, and visual instructions. They can walk up to a custom joint, adjust their angle, and fuse the metal.
Right. They just adapt on the fly.
Exactly. To get a robot to do that same weld, you need an engineer to CAD model the exact spatial path. You have to build a massive custom metal jig to hold the pieces within a millimeter of tolerance so the robot doesn't miss.
Wow.
And you have to build safety enclosures around the whole setup.
So the overhead isn't just the robot arm. It's the entire infrastructure required to make the robot's blind environment predictable?
Which is exactly why a robotic welding setup ends up costing about five times more than simply hiring a human being. The human brain and hand are infinitely cheaper and more adaptable than building a custom jig for every new task.
That makes total sense. But wait, what about the taxi drivers? They topped the exposure index. And we see autonomous taxis driving around certain cities right now.
Robotaxis are actually hovering right at cost parity. The hardware has gotten cheaper and the software is capable. But the paper points out that cost isn't the only barrier. Regulation blocks robots from performing about 14% of the physical tasks they're
capable of.
Of course. A city council can just vote to ban autonomous vehicles from their streets, regardless of how cheap they are. Exactly. So we have these massive barricades protecting physical labor. The paper notes that pure capability, largely the lack of human-level manual
dexterity, blocks 70% of tasks. Right. Regulation blocks another 14%. And then human preference blocks another 25%. I mean, even if a robotic daycare worker is cheap and safe, no parent wants a machine dressing their toddler. We demand a
human.
We absolutely do. So given all those barricades, the authors decided to map out a timeline. Historically, the cost of robotics hardware declines by about 3% every year. If you project that 3% decline forward, the math
says it'll take 40 years for robots to become cost-competitive for just 10% of physical work.
40 years just to hit 10%. That means we wouldn't see robots taking over half of all physical work until the year 2085.
Right. And even in their most aggressive fast-track scenario where hardware prices just plummet, half of the work still isn't cost-competitive until 2050.
But forecasting technology three to six decades into the future is inherently risky, right?
Very risky. So to validate those distant timelines, the authors did something really clever. They ran a back test. They took their exact same rubric and applied it to the robotics technology available back in the year 1977. Oh,
that's smart.
Yeah. And then they tracked what actually happened to the wages and employment of the jobs most exposed to that 1970s tech over the subsequent decades.
And what did the historical data show?
It showed a slow, grinding decline. Jobs highly exposed to 1977 robots did eventually suffer wage stagnation and employment drops, but it took years to materialize.
Wow.
They calculated that, historically, robots learn how to do about 2% of the physical work they previously couldn't do every single year.
You know, this historical backtest perfectly aligns with our final background source, Duran Esamoglu and Pascual Restrepo's 2020 paper, Robots and Jobs.
Yes, exactly.
They looked at specific U.S. commuting zones and found that for every single additional industrial robot introduced per 1,000 workers, employment and wages locally dropped. So this anthropic backtest confirms the Acemoglu Restrepo data. Automation
does destroy specific jobs, but it is a slow, hyper-local bleed, not an overnight apocalypse.
The data is really robust. But, you know, we have to address the elephants in the room here. There are several major tensions in this anthropic paper that require some critical pushback.
I am so glad you brought that up because I have some serious issues with how this study is constructed. First of all, the entire index relies on Claude, an LLM, rating the tasks, scraping the web, and estimating the costs of industrial hardware. We are literally asking
an AI to grade its own homework. Pricing data for enterprise robotics is notoriously opaque. Companies don't just list a $2 million packaging machine on a website with a buy now button. How much can we really trust an AI's judgment on nuanced physical capabilities and hidden costs?
It is a profound limitation. LLMs hallucinate, and they definitely struggle with reasoning about physical physics. Right. The authors try to mitigate this by having Claude cite every single source it used to prove a robot exists and can do the task.
But at the end of the day, using software to evaluate the limitations of hardware introduces a layer of abstraction that might obscure the truth on the factory floor.
Yeah, exactly. And the second tension for me is the reliance on the back test. Forecasting the future based on a linear 2% learning rate from 1977 feels dangerous.
Why do you say that?
Well, right now, there are billions of dollars flowing into humanoid robotics. Machines with two legs, two arms, and tactile hands, designed specifically to use human tools. If a company deploys a fully functional humanoid that can walk onto a messy construction site, doesn't that
completely break the E0 to E3 rubric?
It would completely leapfrog it. The anthropic rubric assumes robots are largely purpose-built for specific tasks in controlled spaces. A true, general-purpose humanoid collapses the environmental control barrier entirely. Right. If the robot can
adapt to the chaos as well as a human, the need for an E1 or E2 environment vanishes. But the authors would counter that while humanoid prototypes look great in edited promotional videos, deploying them at scale, reliably, and cheaper than
a minimum wage human, that is still decades away.
Which leads to my third and final tension, the source itself. The authors work for Anthropic, which is one of the most powerful AI labs on the planet.
Yes, they do.
You have to wonder if there is an inherent institutional bias here. Like, is there a subtle motivation to publish a paper showing that AI and robotics are powerful, but they aren't going to cause mass overnight unemployment? It certainly helps keep the regulators at bay if the threat
is 40 years away.
We always have to scrutinize the source. But this critique actually brings us to one of the most important economic concepts in the automation debate, the productivity paradox.
Oh, right.
This is a phenomenon first observed by economist Robert Solow in the 1980s when he noted that computers were everywhere except in the productivity statistics. Acemoglu and Resprepo, along with another paper by Jones and Tenetti, emphasize this
heavily.
Unpack the mechanics of that productivity paradox for us. Why doesn't new tech immediately equal lost jobs and massive profits?
Because exposure is not automation. Simple cost parity, where a robot costs the exact same as a human, is not enough to trigger a revolution.
What do you mean?
Imagine you run a factory. If a robot costs $20 an hour to operate and a human costs $20 an hour, you're going to keep the human.
Oh, because firing your staff, redesigning your factory floor, hiring robotics engineers, dealing with downtime, that's a massive headache. The switching costs are enormous.
Precisely. For a society to see real productivity gains, and for a business owner to actually go through the friction of ripping out their human workforce, the technology must be drastically, unbelievably cheaper than human labor.
It has to be an undeniable advantage.
Right. Until that massive cost gap opens up, the technology just sits there as a cool prototype.
Furthermore, as David Otter pointed out back in 2015, automation complements labor just as often as it substitutes it.
Yes.
If a construction site gets an autonomous bulldozer, the human operator might lose the job of sitting in the cab pulling levers. But now they are standing on the edge of the site with an iPad. They're managing a fleet of three autonomous dozers, checking the grading and solving complex problems the machines get stuck
on.
So when we synthesize everything we've dug into today, a very clear picture emerges of the modern workforce.
Yeah. If you are looking at this data and wondering who needs to be watching their back first, the targets are highly specific. It is the vehicle operators, the taxi drivers, and the warehouse packers. The capabilities and the unit economics are converging
rapidly on those specific roles.
But if you are a nurse navigating the emotional and physical unpredictability of a hospital ward, or a mechanic reaching your hand blindly into an engine block to feel for a stripped bolt, your job is fiercely protected. The need for complex physical
manipulation and the ability to operate in highly unstructured environments form a moat that multimillion-dollar robots simply cannot cross today.
Which brings us back to the grand, unexpected irony of our time. Every science fiction writer in the 1950s predicted this backward.
They really did.
We were absolutely certain that the robots would master the physical world first. We thought they would take over the heavy lifting, the digging, the cleaning, freeing humanity up to pursue poetry, art, and complex thought.
And instead, the exact opposite has happened. The AI cognitive wave is easily writing the poetry and generating the art, threatening the white-collar workers with bachelor's degrees.
Meanwhile, the physical robotics wave is on this slow, grinding 40-year march, just struggling to figure out how to fold a towel or navigate a messy room.
It's wild.
It really is. Which leaves us with a final, slightly haunting thought for you to chew on as you go about your day. Let's assume that AI software continues to advance exponentially, becoming hyper-intelligent. But let's also assume this anthropic paper is right,
and the physical hardware of robotics remains incredibly expensive and brittle for decades to come. What does the future of work look like in that gap? Will we see a world where humans continue to do the manual physical labor of the economy, not because we possess some magical,
irreplaceable human spirit, but simply because a human body requiring just food and water is the cheapest, most adaptable piece of hardware available to take physical orders from a hyper-intelligent AI boss?
Wow. That is a deeply sobering economic possibility. The robots might not replace us. We might just become their hands.
And on that note, we'll let you get back to the real world. Thanks for taking the deep dive with us today.